okay so last time we uh finished the
first chapter which was about GPS
and I think by now
um You should have a a pretty good
understanding of generally how the
course works so we start with very basic
basically description of the principle
of operation of a given sensor type then
from there we start from basically close
to scratch physics principles we develop
how on the physics level the system the
sensor works and then from there we
build up to a full system level analysis
and understanding of the sensor so this
is going to be basically the flow of the
course moving forward every chapter we
pick a new type of the sensor and
basically go very deep in it so we
finished GPS chapter 2 is initial
sensors then we are going to talk about
ultrasonic sensors radar lidar and
finally cameras okay
uh before we start initial sensors I
also want to say something very
important which is uh most of the Core
Concepts that we develop and talk about
regarding uh different kinds of sensors
um you should uh
um kind of take them as Concepts that
can go beyond just the sensor that we're
talking about
and those Concepts could be very useful
in other types of applications so very
concretely for instance in the context
of GPS we introduced this idea of
ranging codes and doing time of flight
measurements using these pseudorandom
noise sequences now this concept of
course it's it's it was introduced as
part of the how the GPS works but you
can think of it being used in many other
types of sensing right so anywhere that
you want to measure basically a distance
from a time of flight you can use the
idea of M sequences or pseudorandom
noise sequences with the correlations
and everything that we talked about so
same concept for instance
if you modulate a laser light with those
sequences you can imagine that maybe you
can make a lidar with it or if you
modulate millimeter waves with it maybe
you can make a radar with it if you
modulate sound waves with these ranging
sequences maybe you can make a good
ultrasonic sensor with it and those are
exactly throughout the course you would
see that we'll come back to these core
ideas so again as we talk about things
don't tie them just to the
specific application and the system that
we're talking about think about these as
general ideas
that that can be used in other contexts
and for design of other systems okay
with that any questions about GPS before
we start chapter two
no all right so let's start talking
about inertial sensors
so
when we talked about navigation we said
that essentially you need three things
to do a good navigation you need mapping
you need localization and you need
odometry right now a GPS specifically
for instance is a sensor that helps us a
lot with localization and also provides
some limited odometry so you can get
your velocity basically out of the GPS
signals now when it comes to
localization there is uh two main types
of localization techniques one is called
position fixing which is exactly what
the GPS does so basically you receive
some signals or beacons
from external transmitters and using
those signals by some processing you're
able to fix your position or localize
yourself so that's position fixing is is
for instance what the GPS does then the
second type of technique it's called
dead reckoning and that Reckoning is
basically
you localize yourself using odometry so
you start from say a known position you
know where you are right now and if you
know your velocity
um so you know in what direction you're
moving by what speed you can basically
in small time steps deduce your Delta in
position how much your position is going
to change and by just integrating that
over time you can build up a trajectory
of your movement and continuously
localize yourself so that's the idea of
dead reckoning and
uh these two techniques that Reckoning
and position fixing
um in most systems that uh need to
navigate in complex environments uh they
do both of them because uh in in many
ways they are uh complementary to each
other as as we'll see I'm not going to
go into detail of why exactly they're
complementary right now we'll get back
to this towards the end of this chapter
after we've learned how that Reckoning
works because we don't exactly know how
all the details of that Reckoning but
what's important to note now is that
inertial sensors which are also referred
to as initial measurement units or Imus
are one of the key enabling Technologies
for dead reckoning localization and and
navigation
so with the way that Reckoning works is
that say you have some robot that's
moving on some trajectory and at each
point in time if you from your odometry
you get the velocity Vector of the robot
relative to some Global external frame
of reference so in this picture we are
taking say the geographical North
direction as our Global reference frame
and the velocity Vector basically tells
you in what direction and by what amount
you would move with respect to your
Global reference frame in each time step
so you can basically integrate that
start from some initial position at time
T1 and then integrate your velocity from
T1 to T2 and that gives you the position
at at time T2 so you basically if you
continuously integrate you can do your
dead reckoning that way uh if you don't
have continuous functions you can
discretize this and do kind of like a
discrete integration over time okay
so
um
when it so so that Reckoning requires
odometry right you need to know your
velocity and there's different ways of
uh doing odometry simplest one is called
the contact odometry so that's basically
by measuring motion uh uh by via direct
contact to reference frame or reference
surface so that's for instance how cars
do odometry they basically count the
number of rotations of the tire on the
road and that's how the car tells you
the speed that you're moving at
um then we have visual odometry visual
odometry basically uses uh images either
2D or 3D images from a camera or from a
radar or from a lidar and then from
these images or a series of images which
you can think of as frames of a video
for instance from those frame by frame
it extracts some basically visual
features these are typically geometrical
features like corners of certain objects
and and other things and then by doing
some math it basically tracks how these
features are changing frame by frame and
from there you can deduce basically
odometry or how how the
how you were moving
and the third one which we will talk in
a lot of detail in this chapter is
inertial odometry and in initial
odometer you basically start by
measuring acceleration not velocity
directly from some forces that are
applied onto your sensors you measure
acceleration and then if you integrate
the acceleration you get velocity and
then you can integrate your velocity to
do that Reckoning so um how are these
three types of odometeries related
contact odometry
UM
is is uh can be very accurate but it's
not always possible Right you might not
have a surface contact that that that
lets you measure uh velocity for
instance when an airplane that's flying
or a drone that's flying you cannot make
contact to any reference surface for
that
uh so that's the limitation of contact
odometry visual odometry can be very
very accurate but it has two issues one
is that it's computationally expensive
you need to do uh complex uh computer
vision algorithm to extract features
from uh to your 3D
frames of data and then kind of do
additional math on that to to do
odometry and the other limitation of it
is that it can it can or it usually is
pretty slow because uh the sensors that
give you images for instance if it's a
camera typically runs at about 30 frames
a second if it's a radar or a lidar
things can be at 10 frames a second so
you don't get your odometry updates very
frequently and inertial odometry it also
has its pros and cons it can be very
fast so you can get update rates of up
to a few hundreds of Hertz up to a
kilohertz or so which is very fast
but because you don't directly measure
measure velocity we start from
acceleration and then you need to
integrate that to get to Velocity biases
and other noises get into the
integration and can make it a little
inaccurate
but still inertial odometry is extremely
extremely useful and some systems in
fact can entirely run on inertial
odometry and and perform very very well
okay
so
um let's start with uh the principle of
inertia which is kind of like the
underlying physics principle of how Imus
work and basically this principle says
if you have any object it will continue
moving at its its current velocity until
a force is applied to it which causes
the speed or the direction of the of the
object to change okay so from this we
basically can conclude that uh it's
really the forces that we need to
measure that then can tell us something
about the acceleration and ultimately
the velocity of of the object right
because if there's no Force there's no
change in the movement of the object
which means there's nothing we can
measure initially right
so specifically there is two types of
motion uh in in objects that uh
are tied to specific forces that are
applied first we have linear motion and
this is
um possibly one of the most uh basic uh
things that that are taught in physics
classes which is basically uh Newton's
law of motion which says Force equals
mass times acceleration and your
acceleration is the second derivative of
a position with respect to time so f
equals m p double dot and the double dot
means the second derivative it's a more
compact notation for the second
derivative okay so that's linear motion
this should be very familiar then we can
have a rotational motion and it's a
slightly more complicated so when it
comes to rotational motion there are
three forces that can cause rotational
motion uh the first two are called the
centrifugal and coriolis forces and
those are proportional to the angular
velocity or Omega of an object and then
there's what is called the Euler Force
which is proportional to the angular
acceleration of the object if you have
not heard of these forces centrifugal
coriolis Euler forces at all no worries
we will develop them from from first
principles so you do not need any prior
knowledge about these but if you have
heard of them I think it's still going
to be very interesting because you will
see how we can use them to build sensors
okay
so
um with this
um
let's start with like what is the
simplest inertial sensor one can build
it turns out it's a bucket of water
that's the very simplest initial sensor
you can have and we can just make a
simple thought experiment called the
Newton's bucket experiment and we kind
of understand how it works so if you
have a bucket half filled with water and
the signal you get out of this sensor is
you just observe the surface of the
water in this bucket and let's see what
we can measure from that okay if there
if if the bucket is at rest it's not
moving at all of course there's no
signal right you get a perfectly level a
water surface also if it's moving but at
a constant velocity as we know if
there's no linear acceleration still the
surface of the water would be perfectly
level so uh position or location and
velocity we cannot measure with this
initial sensor or in fact with any
inertial sensor but as soon as you start
accelerating it linearly uh the the
water surface becomes slanted like this
and that gives you a signal that is
somehow related or correlated to linear
acceleration so that kind of tells us
that this initial sensor somehow with it
we can measure the linear acceleration
okay what about rotation it turns out
that rotational motion you can also
measure it as soon as you start rotating
this bucket about its axis the surface
of the water starts becoming kind of
like a bow which is also a very unique
shape which gives us a signal which we
can use to basically
indirectly measure rotational motion
okay so this kind of a very simple
thought experiment tells us the kinds of
things that we can and cannot measure
initially okay of course this is not not
a useful sensor we'll talk about useful
ones but it's it's a starting point to
kind of see like how these forces are
related to the quantities we are
interested in in measuring
so with this there are two very distinct
types of inertial sensors that we will
talk about first is accelerometers and
and these as the name suggests that they
measure linear acceleration or a and
then there's gyroscopes which measure
angular velocity Omega and these operate
on different but closely related physics
principles as as we'll see so first
we'll spend some time
um basically today uh we'll talk about
accelerometers and then next time uh
we'll we'll talk about gyroscopes okay
so
um let's let's talk about some
technologies that can enable us uh
basically build an accelerometer there's
different kinds of Technologies but at
the core of them there's what we call a
motion transduction mechanism and what a
motion transaction mechanism is it
basically is a mechanism that transforms
a external force that you apply to the
sensor into a quantifiable signal okay
and we'll see like what the quantifiable
signal is and how we actually quantify
it but the mechanism so if if you apply
a force you need to somehow extract a
measurable signal out of it because as
we just said acceleration is in in
linear motion it's it's proportional to
force so if you can get a quantifiable
signal out of a force that is applied
then hopefully you can with some simple
transformation get acceleration out of
it okay so what what are different types
of motion transaction mechanisms there's
many different
technologies that can enable this and
this list is not comprehensive but it
captures the most common ones so you can
have a mechanical
systems that do this for you it can be
Optical your motion transduction using
some Optical phenomena you can actually
get a quantifiable Optical signal out of
forces it could be based on Surface
acoustic waves or it can be based on
fluids or or fluid fluid mechanics now
the more the most common one which also
is the most for most applications is the
most accurate
technology to work with is mechanical
and that's the one that we will talk in
great detail about so mechanical
accelerometers almost in every robotic
application uh the the
accelerometers that are used are based
on a mechanical motion transduction
and these days these are typically
fabricated using mems or
microelectromechanical Machining
Technologies and we'll see some examples
of that
okay so how do you do motion
transduction mechanically it's actually
uh very very simple the architecture
it's just a damped uh spring Mass system
or a damped harmonic oscillator so you
have some mass and uh you basically have
a spring and a dampener inside an
enclosure and the enclosure is typically
basically your silicon chip that that
becomes the sensor ultimately
so the spring Mass system or The Damp
harmonic oscillator has three components
there's of course the mass of some
quantity M it's called proof Mass
typically so that's just something that
moves and generates some Newtonian Force
then there is a spring with some
constant K and this spring basically
couples forces that are applied to the
enclosure of your sensor to the mass
okay so that's how how you couple force
and then you have some damping mechanism
where the damping Factor B and the the
reason you need the damping is that
without any damping applied as you apply
a force and couple it to a mass with a
spring depending on like this specific
waveform of the force applied you can
have behaviors like resonances or
overshoots which are not desired for
sensing so the damping mechanism
basically
controls the Dynamics of this mass and
make it a little uh basically better
behaved for for the sensing applications
so here's a very simple diagram of a
mechanical one-dimensional accelerometer
so this system is only gonna measure
acceleration applied say in an x-axis
here horizontally okay so we have the
enclosure here again this could be a the
Silicon chip
there's some external Force applied and
due to that Force this entire enclosure
is going to accelerate right
um linearly and that is the acceleration
we want to measure or the sensor will
measure so the sensor will measure the
acceleration of its uh full enclosure
right now internal to the sensor as we
said there is a a damped harmonic
oscillator so you have your spring with
constant K with some uh connected to
some mass and then you have some damping
mechanism here I'm showing it as a kind
of like a dashboard but as as we'll see
this is this is not how it's physically
built there's other ways of basically
adding dampening to the to the spring
Mass system
but what's important here so we're going
to study the Dynamics of this system so
again as as uh as usual we need to
um
make sure our uh for for every quantity
we're gonna talk about which in this
case for instance is the displacement of
this mass is the key quantity we'll talk
about uh we need to specify in what
frame of reference that is measured okay
so here we are if you have two two
frames of references one is the external
one which is kind of your your Global or
your world coordinates right
um and in in this coordinate say your
your enclosure the box has some position
we call x sub b b for box right so so
that's in the world coordinates then you
go inside our enclosure internal to that
you can have another uh reference frame
fixed to the box and relative to that
your mass can have some displacement
which we call X okay so X is the
displacement of the max proof Mass
relative to the enclosure and x sub B is
the position of the enclosure in the the
world coordinates okay so then
um what is the position of the mass in
the world coordinates if you call that X
tilde it would be X Plus x b right so x
b is where the box is relative to the
reference point of the external
coordinates and then you add the
internal displacement of the mass to it
so X Plus x b is X tilde which is the
position of the proof Mass relative to
the external reference frame it's very
very important
to keep track and always clarify what
different frames of references is and
here you're starting simple as we go
throughout this chapter you would see it
becomes more more important and a little
more complex to keep track of our frames
of references especially when we start
introducing rotational motion then
Things become a little more complicated
not too complicated but uh just kind of
like train yourselves to always track
and Define your frames of references
very clearly okay any questions so far
all right let's continue so what we're
going to do now is we're gonna basically
see in this simple uh mechanical setup
uh how is the displacement of the proof
Mass related to the acceleration of the
enclosure and if there is some simple
relationship between the two that can
define basically a mapping or a transfer
function that goes from external
acceleration to the displacement of the
proof mass and then if we invert that
function basically we can calculate
acceleration from X okay we have not yet
talked about okay how do we actually
measure X that would that is going to
come later for now we're just going to
establish at a physics level are these
two quantities even related in a
in an interesting way useful way or not
okay so that's we are still at the
physics level okay so let's talk about
accelerometer physics so the total force
that the proof Mass experiences is the
sum of two components the total inertial
Force there is the force of the spring
and there's the force of the damping
system right so your initial Force
applied to the proof mass m is the sum
of the spring Force plus the damping
Force so let's build a very simple uh
model of what these forces are so what
is the initial Force applied to the mass
that's just Newton's law right so that's
mass times acceleration and the
acceleration of the proof mass is X
tilde double dot y x tilde because this
is the force in the global reference
frame right that's we're talking in the
in the world
coordinates that's the acceleration of
the the proof Mass so m x t Lee double
dot what is the force applied by this
spring if we plug in the very simplest
physics model of a spring using hoof's
law it's linear and it's the the spring
constant times the displacement or the
displacement of the of the spring
internal to the box so the force of the
spring is minus KX what is the dampening
Force again there's different models
we're going to go with the simplest one
which is linear dampening and that's
your dampling Factor times the velocity
of the the proof mass and again this is
the velocity internal to the box right
that's why this one is x dot because it
matters in internally how fast it's
moving relative to the enclosure and
that determines how much dampening Force
it's is applied to it okay so we have
these three quantities defined let's
plug them into our Force equation up
above and also remember that we have X
tilde which is the position of the mass
in the external reference frame is equal
to X Plus XB XP was the position of the
box in the global frame and X was just a
displacement of the mass internal to the
box so we plug those in and we get M
times x double dot plus x b double dot
equals minus KX minus b x dot okay now
um the key thing to note is that x b
double dot the second derivative of x b
is the acceleration of the enclosure
right because XB was the position of the
enclosure in the in the global reference
frame so the second derivative of that
is the external acceleration applied to
the enclosure which is exactly what we
want our sensor to measure right so we
are looking to measure this a external
which is XP double dot okay so let's uh
um plug that in there and then with a
simple rearrangement of the of the
equation this is what we get we get a
second order uh linear differential
equation which relates X to a external
right so it's X double dot plus p over m
x dot plus K Over MX equals negative a
external so now we are onto something
right so now we have uh basically I got
in this
linear Dynamics equation that relates
the displacement of the proof Mass
internal to the box right relative to
the enclosure to the external
acceleration that is that is applied
okay
very good so next step is to see if we
can solve this differential equation and
directly because here we have like the X
and its first derivative and the second
derivative it's it's interesting but
still not useful for for sensing and
measurement so if you can solve this and
directly find the relationship between X
and A then we we can claim that we are
onto something really useful for for
sensing okay so let's try to solve our
uh linear Dynamics equation there's
different ways of solving it the one I I
like is using Fourier transform so
um from the concept of Fourier
transforms we know that any specific
Force applied which is a function of
time any waveform force waveform that
you apply F external of T you can
basically decompose it using the the
concept of Fourier transform into a
bunch of complex exponentials so you can
write it as a summation or an integral
of a bunch of terms which are Each of
which is some F0 times e to the J Omega
T okay that's just the concept of
Fourier transforms and because it's a
summation and because the the uh
differential equation we are trying to
solve as linear uh we just need to find
a solution for one of these complex
exponentials and then using the
superposition principle we can basically
sum the solutions up for for different
terms and come up with a more more
General solution so let's let's start
focusing on just a very simple harmonic
Force applied to our accelerometer and
see if we can solve the Dynamics
equations for that
so knowing that force and acceleration
are linearly dependent so f is just m
times a we know that if our f is a
simple harmonic term acceleration is
also going to be some a0 times e to the
J Omega T right that's just from
Newton's law basically
okay another thing we know is from our
knowledge of a linear dynamical systems
or linear differential equations we know
that if the input
is a pure harmonic to the system knowing
that it's a linear system the output is
also going to be a simple harmonic
function of the same frequency so if
your a is a0 e to the J Omega T your X
of T is also going to be some x0
e to the J Omega T that's just by the
linearity of of the system okay so we
plug things in this this function for a
and this function for X we plug them
into the differential equation we had we
take the derivatives of X and some
common terms factor out and then we are
left with this which is x0 times K Over
M minus Omega squared plus J B Omega
over M times e to the J Omega T equals
minus a0 E to the J Omega T okay now
things are getting really really
interesting uh the e to the J Omega T's
kind of cancel out from both sides and
then we are left with a direct
relationship between x0 and a0 which is
given by this so x0 is this term
don't mind what it is okay it's it's
some stuff but it's some something which
is only a function of Omega
times a0 right and what's and what is X
0 x 0 is the amplitude of motion of the
or the displacement of the proof mass
and a0 is the amplitude of the
acceleration it's harmonic acceleration
that's being applied and these two are
directly
proportional to each other and uh what
is the proportionality constant it's -1
over to simplify the notation we have
introduced this new variable Omega 0
which is the square root of K Over M so
that's related to the mass and the and
the spring constant in this way and then
it's minus 1 over Omega 0 squared minus
Omega squared plus b JB
Omega over m
okay so now we have something actionable
and and useful and basically the key
conclusion that we have come to is that
the displacement of the proof mass x of
T is proportional to the acceleration
that is applied so now we are on to
something
useful and actionable because if we can
somehow measure X of t
then using this transformation we can
find a from it does that make sense
okay so now you're you're building
something useful again started from very
very simple principles but we already
after a little bit of uh math and
physics we are on to something uh useful
okay
um one side note here so you might ask
um when we were doing this we said that
our acceleration is a0 e to the J Omega
T and also this function that we have
found for X is a complex function but
these are physical quantities so like a
displacement cannot be complex it has to
be real valued physically so is there a
disconnect here or did we cheat or or
what happened and we do not cheat it's
actually a very common practice in in
physics and and other engineering fields
that to to simplify the math we've
worked with complex valued functions
these complex exponentials but the
physical quantity is tied to each of
these functions are actually just the
real real parts of of these functions so
for instance the physical value of
acceleration is the real part of this a0
to the J Omega t or the physical
displacement of the proof Mass the
quantity that you would actually
physically measure is just a real part
of that complex function but we use
complex functions because it makes the
math a lot easier to track like things
like derivatives or cross terms instead
of having to work with Sines and cosines
and things like that it's just a lot
easier to work with these complex
exponentials that's the only reason okay
you could do all this working with
physical quantities so you could start
with your Force being some F0 times
cosine Omega T actually we did that in
the last chapter for GPS and I did it
deliberately so it you if you go remind
yourself of what the math looked like in
the GPS it was a lot of cross stems
cosine squared cosine times sine and
things like that but you could do
basically the same thing with a much
more concise and elegant math if you use
this idea of complex explanations okay
and we use both of these again I want
you to be comfortable with both types of
parametrizations of formulations of
these functions so throughout the course
you would see sometimes I use complex
exponentials sometimes I use actual
signs and cosines as as physical
quantities and it's it's it's a very
deliberate it's not to make things
inconsistent I actually want you to be
comfortable to work with on both of
these representations
okay so with that
now we have a very direct relationship
between displacement and and
acceleration right and uh we can
actually derive what is called a
transfer function now for this uh for
for this system so the transfer function
is uh basically uh exactly the the the
the relationship between our X and A so
if I go two slides back and let's
actually write this on the board
um so we found that our x0
the amplitude of the displacement is
-1 over
uh what is it Omega squared
is it plus Omega 0 squared
minus J B
Omega over M something like that or plus
and minus this is a plus okay minus plus
times a0 right so from this if we look
at the ratio of of x to a the
displacement to the acceleration applied
that's what we call a transfer function
so h of Omega
the transfer function is x0 over a or a0
which is exactly this term minus one
Omega squared minus Omega 0 squared plus
J B Omega over F okay so that's our uh
TF for transfer function
um and uh normally to study like the the
the high level
behavior of the system or input output
relationship of the system this is a
complex valued function it's very common
to look at its amplitude uh
and and face separately especially the
amplitude of this function basically
tells you
um is the system for instance as a an
acceleration is applied for different
frequencies which is Omega is the
frequency of the applied acceleration if
you look at the amplitude of this guy
um is it flat across frequency is it
going to go up and down like does it
amplify does it attenuate or does it
just scale and and pass through the
signal so looking at the amplitude of
the transfer function as a function of
frequency is uh very insightful in terms
of what to expect from this system so if
we take the amplitude of H of Omega
that's just this function 1 over the
square root of of this theorem and it's
a function of Omega if you have a
studied electric circuits or maybe some
dynamical systems this might be familiar
to you as the transfer standard transfer
function of a second order low pass
filter if you have not seen this not a
problem let's plot it and see what it
looks like right so we can now plot this
amplitude of H as a function of Omega
the input frequency and this is what it
looks like there's three curves here I'm
going to talk about like what what the
differences are but before that note
that this is a log log plot plot both
the x-axis and the y-axis are
logarithmic and also they're normalized
so the x-axis instead of uh just
plotting versus frequency if you're
we're plotting versus normalized
frequency which is Omega over this Omega
0 that that we have defined okay that's
just one thing to note and and we did
this so uh we can basically have one
plot that kind of captures all different
types of systems now high level as you
see at low frequencies we have a pretty
flat response okay which is a very
desired Behavior because this means that
for for inputs uh whose frequency are
much lower than Omega zero so when Omega
over Omega 0 is a small like 10 to the
minus 3 10 to the minus 2 10 to the
minus 1 and so on
the amplitude response is constant which
means what the system does what this
transfer function does is just a scaling
right your output X is just proportional
to a with a scale factor that is depend
that is determined by H there's no
frequency dependent variations okay and
then if you look at very high
frequencies like above
Omega over Omega 0 equals to one around
this part of the plot you see that all
of them start going down and that's why
it's a low pass filter right so inputs
are very high frequencies are going to
get filtered out or significantly
attenuated inputs that are low frequency
they're just going to go scaled and then
there is kind of like your your uh
the cutoff frequency as we call it and
different types of behaviors can happen
around this frequency which is Omega
equal to Omega 0 right that's that's
your 10 to the zero uh vertical line and
the different types of behavior that can
happen they uh are strictly determined
by how much damping you have in your
system uh first let's look at the red
curve which kind of Peaks around here
and when it Peaks it means that for some
frequencies that are close to Omega 0
your filter is going to start amplifying
them right so you get like a larger
amplitude response from your filter and
that's called an underdamp system and
under damping happens when the value of
the damping Factor B is less than 2
square root of M times K okay now the
smaller the B is this peak is going to
become larger and larger and larger and
in the case that your B is zero you can
actually have an undamped system which
can basically in theory it can blow up
and give you like an infinite response
but in practice we always have some
amount of damping
um so so this never becomes really
Infinity but it can Peak pretty high
that is an undesired Behavior right you
don't want these uh resonances or or
very large amplitude oscillations to
happen in your system you want something
that has a very nice flat response right
um
and then if you look at the yellow curve
which is an overdamp system so that
happens when your value of B is very
large specifically larger than two root
M times K it's okay it's flat it doesn't
resonate or anything but you're kind of
eating into the bandwidth of the system
so if you think of it as a low pass
filter as you increase your damping
Factor this cutoff frequency which is
where you're basically the knee of the
curve is starts becoming lower and lower
and lower and that's also not a desired
Behavior because why it into the
bandwidth of the system that means a
higher frequency inputs are not going to
generate a response that we can measure
okay we want as as large a bandwidth as
as we can have typically without any
instabilities and things like that so
kind of The Sweet Spot between the over
damped and under damped is what we call
the critically damped system and that's
when B is exactly equal to 2 root M
times K and for those systems the cutoff
frequency is exactly a the 3db cutoff
frequency is exactly equal to Omega zero
okay and that's kind of a usually it's a
it's a desired type of behavior for a
system to be to be critically critically
damped okay does this make sense the
frequency response and how these
different types of behaviors can can
happen in the in the mechanical system
okay
uh so
when you have an input whose frequency
is much much lower than the bandwidth of
your system which as we just saw is
generally speaking determined by this
Omega 0 that's a bandwidth again this
was Omega equals Omega 0 line so
generally speaking that's kind of
roughly determines the bandwidth of your
system if your inputs are much lower in
frequency than that
then we have a very very simple
relationship between displacement and
acceleration which let's actually look
at it here together
um so so so this top expression is the
general real this is always correct
right whatever Omega is you have this
relationship between x0 and a0 but if
you look at omegas that are much smaller
than Omega 0 right so if you make the
assumption that Omega is much much less
than
Omega 0
then what happens the approximation you
can make here is uh okay so so this term
is negligible compared to Omega zero and
and this term is also negligible right
anything that has Omega in it is is
negligible and then you basically just
get a a linear relationship between your
X here and a which is minus 1 over Omega
0 is squared and remember Omega 0 was
the square root of K Over M so this is
also equal to in terms of the the proof
mass and the and the spring constant
it's minus M over k a zero okay so when
inputs are well within the bandwidth of
the system you get a very simple just a
scale factor relationship direct
proportionality between displacement and
applied acceleration okay now this
Factor here this number is called the
sensitivity of our accelerometer because
it's basically tell you for a given
acceleration how much displacement
you're going to have inside the
accelerometer and that's the that's the
sensitivity Now by looking at this
expression of course we want a large
sensitivity right we want as large a
response as possible for a given
acceleration so we have a large signal
to measure Now by looking at this
naturally you might think okay so to
have a
large
sensitivity we should increase M we
should have a big Hefty proof Mass to
give us a good sensitivity well
mathematically it makes sense uh in in
practice that's not the case because in
practice
for the application for which you're
designing the sensor that application is
going to kind of require or dictate what
bandwidth your sensor needs to have
right so it's say whatever avionics
application and you know that your
inputs are going to be up to 500 Hertz
of vibrations or whatever and you need
to measure those types of acceleration
so that kind of sets what
Omega 0 is going to be for that
application and once you fix your Omega
0 then then you cannot touch m or k or
the the ratio needs to be constant so
it's actually the Omega 0 that
determines uh your sensitivity it's the
bandwidth of the system right so that's
where a very practical practical reason
uh one one example here so for instance
let's say you are designing an
accelerometer for an airbag application
okay so an airbag accelerometer it needs
to respond very quickly right as soon as
there is impact it needs to be able to
to respond to it so a typical response
time and again these are some just
typical ballpark numbers I've thrown in
the typical response time say it's a
quarter of a millisecond
so then that means the bandwidth you
require from your accelerometer is
roughly speaking one over your response
time so one over Tau which is four
kilohertz
okay and from that bandwidth you just
found your Omega zero which is 2 pi
times F so 2 pi times uh four thousand
radians per second and once this this is
set that means your
um your sensitivity is also set okay so
practically speaking
um um it's it's you don't you don't
determine your sensitivity by proof Mass
so you don't improve it by adding proof
Mass because you have a requirement for
your Omega zero okay for this reason
um
uh it's practically speaking you can we
can say that the sensitivity is actually
independent of the proof Mass it's just
said by the bandwidth and uh because of
this the the modern accelerometers they
actually have very very small proof
masses they're in the microgram range in
terms of the mass uh which is which is
very very small that's for a very
practical reason
any questions so far
okay
let's continue so we talked about an
input which was just a simple harmonic
right just one of these yes of course
the spring or the damper contribute to
that pedal wouldn't that be significant
in relation to the mess of the
actual mess yeah so the question is if
the actual proof mass is just micrograms
uh then you also need to account for the
the the spring itself would have some
mass and the damping system the damping
system will come back to it actually the
way it's
practically implemented it's it has no
contribution to the maps the spring
you're right but as we talk about uh
hopefully today we'll get to a point
where we can talk about how these
sensors are actually manufactured you
would see that for instance in these
mems processes
um the way they're done the spring is
negligible Mass compared to the proof
Mass so if this guy is in micrograms the
spring is like a fraction of a microgram
or less in a way that it actually
still it's dominated by the mass of the
the proof Mass itself
Okay so so um
uh
next thing to talk about is basically
um so so we talked about a simple
harmonic input right so if you just have
some a0 e to the J Omega T we solved our
our differential equation for that and
and found the solution but in general
your inputs are not simple harmonics
they can be any any waveform right some
egg a a external of T is applied and we
need to find the response which is the
displacement but it turns out that again
if we go back to the principle of the of
the Fourier transform and use this
transfer function we have derived h of
of of of
Omega
with this you can basically use this h
of Omega and find the response to any
input so if you have some input a of t
function of time the way you would find
the responses first you take the Fourier
transform of a
to take it to the frequency domain
multiply it by
the transfer function h of Omega and
then take the
inverse Fourier transform of that
and that would be equal
to your X of t
so that's how you do it for a general
input simple as that all you need to
know is really this this transfer
function that we found using the simple
simple harmonic input
uh so with that again we can look at
different types of inputs one that is
particularly interesting is a step input
so if you have an input that a of T that
is zero for negative times and then at
Time Zero it suddenly jumps to some
value a0 right it's a it's a step input
and let's see how the system responds to
that the response is very dependent
again on the damping factor of the
system okay so again the system X of T
it's at rest at zero and then at time
zero that's where you apply your step
right and then that's where X starts
changing right for let's look at the
overdamp system so when you have over
damping the response is very very slow
okay and it's going to take the system a
very long time to get to what we call
the steady state and the steady state is
what you expect it's just the
sensitivity times a0 right so your
steady state response is again minus one
over Omega 0 squared times a 0. okay but
then you have this transient between
where you wear at rest and the steady
state response and the transient takes
some time to basically settle and then
you get to the steady state response
what we really are interested in for
sensing is the steady state response
right the transients we want them to
actually die off pretty quickly because
we can use the steady state response to
find a0 right the transients are kind of
not interesting for sensing then if you
have the the red curve which is an
underdamped system uh it can it can do
some oscillations right it can ring it a
little bit and then get to steady state
here I'm I'm drawing kind of like
exaggerated underdamp system so they
don't all oscillate this much so you can
have something like for instance just a
slight bit of
undershoot and then get to steady state
so the screen can also be at less
underdamped system okay and then the
blue is your uh is your critically uh
critically damped which it doesn't
overshoot or uh it also doesn't take a
long time it kind of settles down in a
kind of like an exponential type type
response okay so those are different
types of
uh responses you can you can expect
the key point is that as you saw all of
them given enough time settle to the
same steady state response over them
under them critically damp they all get
to the same steady state response which
we call x uh substady State and that's
just the sensitivity times times a0 okay
so ultimately you can kind of sort of
argue that you could use either of them
for sensing but if you want a sensor
that does not do uh uh like a a an
unstable oscillations and also does not
take a very long time to respond or to
settle to steady state you would want to
design it to be either critically damped
or slightly under that and in practice
all accelerometers that are made are are
designed to be either critically down to
or slightly under them and by slightly
under damp that's the one that I drew
which can overall undershoot just a
little bit but then it it settles to
steady state very quickly okay
um another thing to note is
um why the negative sign here why is
that our displacement kind of like we
apply a a positive say acceleration and
we get a negative displacement
um intuitively that's the same effect
like say when you're in a car and you
accelerate quickly you get pulled back
right so then in that case you're the
proof Mass the car body is the enclosure
of the inertial sensor and and and your
movement is basically that displacement
that you're sensing so cars accelerating
forward you feel like you're getting
pulled backward and that's exactly where
this negative negative sign is is coming
from
okay so we talked about physics
uh there's one more thing to talk about
before we we close uh close on the
physics and that's it a very subtle
point about non-contact forces
so uh it's very important to note that
the type of accelerometer we have been
describing these mechanical thermometers
can only measure contact forces these
are also called uh specific forces
um you can have non-contact forces of uh
acting on these uh accelerometers but
they're not measurable so a very
interesting thought experiment is that
imagine you take one of these
accelerometers and then let it start
from rest and drop it and let it free
fall in some gravitational field and
let's see if it can measure actually
that gravitational force that is acting
on it so we start at rest our X of T is
zero x dot the velocity of the proof
mass is also zero we are starting at a
perfect stationary and then it's going
to free fall in a gravitational field so
gravity is going to accelerate
everything right the enclosure the proof
Mass the spring everything is gonna
experience the same gravitational force
so X tilde double dot is of course equal
to G so G's say the the the the the
gravitational acceleration of Earth is G
9.8 meters per second squared so XT Lee
double dot that's the proof masses
acceleration is G the body or the
enclosure is also experiencing the exact
same acceleration as their Free Falling
so that means x x double dot which is
the acceleration of the proof Mass
relative to the enclosure which is X to
the double dot minus XP double dot is
zero right so that means putting
everything together if we start at x t
equals zero and the initial velocity is
zero and the initial acceleration is
also zero that means there's not going
to be any displacement for this proof
mass for as long as it's free falling in
in the gravitational field so X of T is
going to be 0 for all T which means we
will get no signal remember X of T is
the signal that we get out of the
examiner we'll get no signal due to this
gravitational force that's that's being
applied on it
um so non contact forces are not
measurable important thing to note
I did not say accelerometer cannot
measure gravity I do not say that right
if it's gravity through contact it can
so say there's an accelerometer in your
phone you put it down on the desk and
now it's experiencing gravitational
force through the contact with the with
the desk surface right because now there
is a counter Force applied from from the
desk equal to negative G to the
accelerometer on this thing and then it
does measure a minus G acceleration
actually through that contact but if I
drop my phone I'm not going to do it but
as it's Free Falling it cannot measure
what the gravitational force is okay
this is very important especially for
certain types of applications in space
and things like that it's important to
know that non-contact forces are not not
measurable okay any questions
all right so let's continue now we want
to uh develop a system level
architecture we talked about we started
from the mechanical architecture of our
accelerometer and now we're gonna extend
it to the system level and specifically
for a system architecture what we have
not done yet is talk about how do we
actually measure the displacement of the
proof Mass right because that's the
signal that is directly proportional to
acceleration and we need to measure that
before we talk about how let's
understand order of magnitude wise what
type of signals we're dealing with in
terms of the displacement of the proof
Mass okay
so let's say there's a acceleration of
0.1 G again G is 9.8 meters per second
squared there's an acceleration of 0.1 G
applied to an accelerometer and our
accelerometer has a 10 kilohertz
bandwidth this is the bandwidth is kind
of high but not outrageously High some
accelerometers have less bandwidth than
this but let's just work with that
number so we plug in the numbers into
the equation we have for x0 and a0 so x0
is minus a0 over Omega 0 squared you
plug in the numbers and your x0 turns
out to be a quarter of a nanometer okay
so we are talking about extremely
extremely small displacements for some
applications especially if you have if
you need to have a large bandwidth and
you need to measure small uh
accelerations then it translates to very
small
displacements uh and that's the
challenge to solve so you need to design
Electronics sensitive enough to be able
to pick up
nanometer scale or even sub nanometer
scale displacements okay and there are
several technologies that have been
successfully deployed for measuring
these kinds of uh
displacements there's Piezo resistive
Technologies the Piezo resistive
basically uh uh translates a mechanical
stress to a change in electrical
resistance and then there's a circuitry
that measures that change in resistance
and that's how it's done then there's
piezoelectric methods which again
translates a mechanical stress to a
change in electrical charge and then you
measure the charge and that's how you
get your displacement and finally
there's capacitive sensors and these
basically translate displacement to a
change in capacitance and then if you
can measure that capacitance that is
basically the signal you want
the capacitive sensing uh is is the most
common technique and also it gives the
best performance in terms of uh sense in
terms of noise and SNR that's the one
we're gonna talk about okay so now the
objective is how do we take this
displacement of the proof Mass
and design something that translates
that to a change in capacitance that we
can then electrically measure the
concept is very simple so again we have
our same mechanical architecture proof
Mass stamped uh with the with the with
the spring and and dampling mechanism
and what what we're going to do is we're
going to add a capacitor assume it's
just a parallel plate capacitor with two
fixed electrodes so those are these two
and then you also apply a fixed voltage
to them so you apply a voltage v0 to
your first fixed plate and then the
second one you can just ground it or or
apply a different voltage to it okay so
you apply known fixed for now voltage to
a parallel plate capacitor and then you
add a third plate which is tied to your
proof mass and then that one can move
inside the fixed capacitor right so with
doing that we essentially are generating
two variable capacitances one between
the first plate and your middle plate so
that's the first one and then that is
the second one so call them C1 and C2
right so these two capacitances as your
proof Mass moves are going to change
right and because of the change in those
capacitances
the electrode that is tied to the proof
mass is going to have different voltages
according to where it is inside the
fixed capacitor right because the the
ratio of the two capacitance is C1 and
C2 is going to determine the voltage of
your moving plate okay now
um turns out that the the the math is
actually extremely simple the voltage
call that V sub X of this moving
capacitor plate is a linear function of
of displacement okay because it's just
it becomes a linear voltage divider
basically according to the position or
the displacement of the center plate and
here's the equation so that your VX
which is the voltage of of the the
moving
electrode is a v 0 over 2 times 1 plus
2X over d X is your displacement and D
is the total separation between the two
fixed plates of the of of the outer
capacitor so just to see that this makes
sense we can plug in some numbers
together and check it so let's start
with when X is zero
uh that's at rest right there's no
displacement and then let's say we've
designed it such that x0 x equals zero
your moving plate is exactly in the
middle of the of the outer capacitor so
if you plug in x equals zero this
becomes v x equals uh V 0 over 2. okay
which kind of makes sense you have a
fixed voltage zero with a uniform
electric field between the two plates
and then you put this third plate right
in the middle you get half the voltage
right if you plug in x equals let's try
one more
um one of the two end limits so D over
two
so that's where you're touching one of
essentially touching one of the the two
capacitors you've displaced by half the
uh half the spacing so if you plug that
and then your VX
becomes equal to v0 which makes sense
you're touching one of the end plates so
the voltage you pick up is exactly equal
to the voltage of that plate if you plug
in x equals minus t over 2 you get the x
equals zero which again makes sense so
so this is just essentially a linear
voltage divider okay and now this is
also interesting because we have uh if
basically with the simple linear
transformation uh we are going from
displacement to a voltage that can be
electrically measured okay and that's
exactly how it's constructed so with
this we can now basically sketch a full
system level diagram of what a
accelerometer architecture looks like
Okay so let's uh walk through this
together so this is our capacitive
sensor again you have your fixed plates
and this middle one is the moving plate
which is tied to the proof Mass I'm not
showing the proof Mass here because this
is kind of like a electrical
architecture diagram but note that this
is tight or are connected physically to
the proof Mass
now what we do instead of applying
buying a fixed DC voltage we actually
applied a modulated voltage with some
modulation frequency Omega C right and
again this is this is always common
practice as we also uh saw in the case
of the GPS as much possible especially
when you're working with small signals
low SNR signals you want to move them
away from DC as much possible the DC
part of the spectrum there's always more
and more noise in it there's one over F
noise there's other type of noise that
kind of pollute the the low frequency
parts of the the Spectrum so all this
cosine Omega CT is doing is basically
just modulating our signal away from DC
so we get less noise and interference
coupling to it okay so then we have X of
T and then the voltage that this plate
picks up is the same expression we had V
0 over 2 times 1 plus 2X over d
modulated by the same carrier frequency
cosine Omega CT and and then after you
pick that up what you do is you can
demodulate that down so multiply it by
the carrier to bring that bring that
back to to baseband you amplify it
and then your low pass filter it we'll
see why the low pass filtering in a
second and then you pass that through an
analog to digital converter you get some
digital measure of uh the voltage of
this plate and then hopefully with some
simple math we can find acceleration
from this digitized or discretized
voltage that that we are measuring one
thing to note is that in cases where
we're working with uh extremely noisy
signals it would be a good practice to
put the amplifier before the down
converter so actually amplify here
instead of here so you amplify your
signal first and then down convert it
and then that from a noise point of view
that's actually a better practice but
mathematically what is here is perfectly
fine and it actually doesn't matter
where you put the amplifier for what
we're doing here in terms of what uh
frequencies for modulation you use you
typically choose a frequency Omega C
that is much larger than the bandwidth
of your the mechanical bandwidth of your
system so a megahertz or a few megahertz
or some some common numbers that that
are that are used okay so now let's
trace the signal through the signal
chain and see uh what what is going to
come out and how it relates to X and
ultimately how it relates to
acceleration okay so we start with
basically this down converted signal
which is just VX times V 0 cosine Omega
T so it just becomes V 0 squared over 2
times this 10 1 plus 2X over D times
cosine squared of Omega CT now as you
know cosine squared it it can be broken
down into two terms it would there would
be a one-half and a cosine of two Omega
CT over two right and this is why we
need a low pass filter so we're going to
pass that through an amplifier that's
just a gain factor of G and then what
the low pass filter does for us is that
it gets rid of the high frequency like
the component of the signal that is at 2
Omega C and just gives us the baseband
component to work with and that's
exactly what happens here so VF of T
that's the signal just before the ADC is
gv0 squared over four
times 1 plus 2X over D so this is great
right because we have this signal which
is directly proportional to the
displacement X of T which is what we
want to measure right and then we
discretize it again as as we see we saw
multiple times in the case of the GPS
there is some sampling interval T sub s
or some sampling frequency F sub s and
then we discretize it and we get this
expression here same as the one above we
just have discretized basically our
displacement so we have X of n instead
of X of t
so that's the digitized signal that
you're going to get out the next step is
how is that related to uh acceleration
how do we so if this is what we get out
of the ADC we should be able to do some
simple math some simple DSP and find
acceleration from it right and it kind
of should be
obvious from here because what what we
have here we see that this V is uh well
there's some scale factor and other
terms but ultimately it's it's a linear
function of X right so I can invert this
and write X as a linear function of F
and then we know the transformation from
X to acceleration is just a scale factor
you just multiply by the sensitivity
essentially and then you get your
acceleration so with two linear like a
scale factor and a simple linear
transformation I should be able to find
my acceleration from this digitized
voltage that we're measuring and that's
exactly how we do again remember when
the input is well within the bandwidth
of uh the the accelerometer the
displacement and the acceleration are
linearly related with this sensitivity
Factor minus 1 over Omega 0 squared and
then as I said if we invert that
previous function which related V and f
x and write X as a function of v instead
that's just a very simple algebra right
you just basically take the trends to
the other side your X of n becomes this
linear function of v d over 2 for V over
g v 0 squared minus 1 and then if we
multiply this by the sensitivity we are
basically done now we have an
accelerometer that gives the Excel the
digitized or the discretized
acceleration as a function of this
voltage that is measured which is the
output of our ADC so at this point we
are completely done we basically have a
full system that can measure
acceleration in one dimension for now we
see how to extend it to two and three
dimensions but essentially it's it's a
fully functional system at this point uh
one thing to note is whenever there is
some ADC sampling our sampling rate
should be above Nyquist of course and
the condition for that is given here so
your T sub s should be less than pi over
Omega 0. another way of writing this
which might be more familiar to you is
that your sampling rate F sub s should
be bigger than twice the largest
frequency in the signal which in our
case is 2 times F 0 right because F0 is
the bandwidth of of our accelerometer so
basically Omega 0 is 2 pi
F0 that's the angular frequency versus
the frequency in hertz
okay
any questions so far does this make
sense yeah
practically where do you usually put
um like FS uh
[Music]
like you know 10 times in order to
actually blow or no so okay so so the
question is okay practically okay this
is mathematically kind of the minimum
right if it's perfectly bad limited the
Nyquist criteria says FS bigger than 2f0
practically uh what do we do it we don't
do exactly two typically we also don't
do 10. um different systems are a little
different but something like I've seen
2.5 I've seen three I've seen four but
not ten because remember like FS it's
when you make your adcs faster and
faster they become more power hungry and
more expensive to make so there is
there's uh other system design
trade-offs but yeah it also depends on
how how
um so we said the system is like a low
pass filter but how sharp that drop or
the after the
Omega zero how how sharp your uh
basically drop off is systems that are
not very sharp like if it was a first
order system you might want to increase
your or sampling rate a little more to
get less aliasing basically
Okay so so this was uh we so far talked
about one architecture for an
accelerometer there is another type of
architecture which is from mechanical
and electrical point of view more
complex but it has uh some some very
distinct benefits to it and and it's
sometimes used okay and that's an
actively controlled accelerometer so the
way they actively control accelerometer
works
um what's that uh the way they actively
control exodometer works is that this
part is exactly the same as what we
talked about so you have your capacitive
sensor you get a signal proportional to
the displacement of the moving plate and
then the amplify it the low pass filter
it we digitize it but then what we do
instead of working with this VF directly
we actually put that in a feedback loop
and what the feedback loop does is that
from this measured voltage it extracts
an error signal and feeds that error
signal to a electrostatic actuator and
what the electrostatic actuator does is
that it can apply
through the electrostatic mechanism a
force to that moving plate which is tied
to our proof mass and this Force through
this air signal is adjusted such that
the proof mass does Almost Doesn't move
at all so it almost just keeps it
stationary as soon as it wants to move
your air your feedback error signal
generates a force and it just keeps it
in position right it doesn't let it move
much so it's almost always at zero our
Mass is at rest and the way this works
for if if the mass is not moving at all
that means the net force applying on it
should be zero which means this
electrostatic force fac should exactly
cancel out the inertial force right so
we should have F AC is my minus F
inertial and remember my f initial is
just the mass the proof mass times its
acceleration x t d double dot which is
minus M times x double dot plus x b
double dot and then if this system works
perfectly if the proof mass is always
almost stationary that means X double
dot should be zero right because if it's
not zero that means the proof mass is
internal to the enclosure it is
accelerating so in a in a perfect case
this term is zero that means your F
acceleration is just minus m x b double
dot and remember XB double dot is the
external acceleration to the enclosure
that we want to measure so in this case
you get this very simple linear
relationship between the force your
actuator is generating and the external
acceleration so you simply calculate a
external by scaling your uh
electrostatic actuators Force by minus 1
over M okay now note that to do do this
we have added a lot of complexity in
Hardware in electronics and in the
mechanical design you need this force
force balance controller you need an
electrostatic actuator and you actually
need to mechanically build the actuation
mechanism but you get a number of very
good benefits one is that in actively
controlled accelerometers they are more
linear they have a much more linear
response and the reason for that is that
specifically when we talked about the
spring in this damped oscillator we
assume the linear model for it right we
assume that the force of the spring is
just the constant times its its
displacement that assumption which is
hooke's law it's accurate when the
displacement is not very large but as
you start displacing more and more the
behavior of the spring becomes
non-linear which means our underlying
physics assumption on which we derived
all these equations it starts to become
a little more inaccurate and eventually
break now but in the actively controlled
system because you you never displace
the mass too much your linearity
assumption is is always valid so that
that really helps and these systems are
much more linear
they're also much faster wider faster
again because the proof Mass doesn't
move much or at all uh you don't need to
wait for the transients to die and get
to the steady state which you can then
use to find your acceleration you are
almost always by definition at steady
state you basically keep your mass at
steady state so these systems actively
Control Systems can have much faster
responses which also means they have
much much more bandwidth and again this
idea of getting more bandwidth with a
feedback loop should be familiar if you
ever studied electrical systems as you
know by generating feedback loops you
can get more bandwidth out of out of
systems finally they are more robust
against fabrication process variations
specifically for instance as you
fabricate these things as we'll talk
about next time there could be
variations in the the the
spring constant K and K is baked into
the sensitivity remember right that
Omega 0 is root K Over M which is the
sensitivity of the not actively
controlled system and when there's
process variations you can't per system
measure your case so you just assume
some nominal value for your sensitivity
and then due to process variations your
system can become more inaccurate and
the actively Control Systems don't have
that why because this is the equation
your a external is just F over M so it
only depends on the proof mass and not
not on K it also doesn't depend for
instance on the spacing between the two
plates of the capacitive sensor so it
has a number of very good benefits but
the trade-off is it's a more complex
system needs more complex Hardware more
complex mechanics more complex control
loops and so on and so forth so both
these types of systems the the regular
one that we talked about and the
actively controlled are built and are
used extensively it's a according to
your application that you need to decide
do you really need an actively
controlled one which is going to be more
expensive and maybe a little more power
consuming or is a regular one good
enough okay I think this is a good spot
to quit for today and then next time
we'll continue any questions
all right see you next time